aujourd'hui l'espagne entre dans la
phase 2 0 de son plan de déconfinement
il s'agit d'une nouvelle transition
plusieurs mesures entrent en vigueur
dans les transports en commun le port du
masque est désormais obligatoire et pour
ce faire six millions de masques seront
distribués dans les principales stations
de métro et arrêts de bus du pays 7
millions seront également remis aux
municipalités
les habitants peuvent également se
procurer en pharmacie au prix fixe
maximum de 96 centimes l'autre nouveauté
du jour concerne les commerces de moins
de 400 mètres carrés
ils ont le droit d'ouvrir mais
uniquement sur rendez vous et à raison
d'un client maximum par employé ça
concerne les boutiques de services
couturière coiffeur centre esthétique et
quincaillerie à l'intérieur du gel
hydroalcoolique doit être à disposition
des clients
et si la distance sociale de deux mètres
ne peut pas être respecté le port du
masque est alors obligatoire
de leur côté les restaurants peuvent
proposer de la vente à emporter et les
clients peuvent désormais récupérer leur
commande à l'intérieur toutefois il faut
que le lieu respectent les mesures de
sécurité c'est à dire qu'un comptoir ou
un paravent soit entre le client et le
serveur et si tout se déroule comme
prévu le pays entrera dans la phase 1 de
son plan de déconfinement le lundi 11
mai